well some breaking news that's likely to
interest students and their parents
students who were supposed to be taking
gcse's
and a level exams this summer let's turn
to our correspondent national
harinag who's got the details on this
ashley this is
people who were scheduled to take those
important exams
they'll be graded by schools in tandem
with qualification boards
but they get to have a go if they don't
like the grade they get is that a first
summary that is a first summary collin
now we were told on the 20th of march
when
all schools and colleges in england they
were due to close
essentially for all of those gcse as a
level students it meant
that they would have to rely on a
predicted grade from their teachers and
that predicted grade essentially is a
reflection of their work
it takes into account things like
previous coursework and assessments for
that year
but we have just found out that they do
have another option for those students
who feel like they
didn't get that accurate reflection of
their performance
for all subjects except for art and
design this is at gcse
as level and a level as well you'll be
able to sit an exam
in autumn that's what they're being told
if however you have done coursework and
you're happy
with your grade you are allowed to stick
with that if you've done your coursework
as well however
done your coursework and you do want to
have a go at sitting the exam
you can do so and your highest grade
will be taken into account now of course
this is going to be a huge a huge
change and a huge decision for some of
those students who
for about three months now haven't been
at school haven't been at college
and they will be sitting at home
thinking what do i do do i take the risk
take the exam and pick the highest grade
if i get it but what if i've moved on if
you've got an a-level student for
example who
is now thinking about university and if
later into the autumn they've already
started and starting their lectures
do they really want to be thinking about
retaking their a level exams
on the off chance they might get a
better grade having said that they have
missed out of course on so much revision
so
is it worth the risk exam boards are now
being told they should start preparing
for these exams to take place in
november
and october time but of course it does
depend on what the health pandemic looks
like at that stage but just a reminder
for those students
who want to take their exam in autumn do
you have the option now to do so